si este escándalo impacta negativamente
en el devenir del perú y particularmente
en lo que es la gestión creo que ha
buscado ser siempre transparente del
gobierno de transición y emergencia que
tenemos desde noviembre del año pasado
no los los entretelones de la
investigación el ensayo clínico todavía
van a ser revelados e investigados con
una comisión multisectorial pero sin
duda en la ciudadanía en la población y
creo que entre la mayoría de analistas
tenemos la sensación de que se ha
aprovechado el cargo de funcionarios
públicos desde más alto funcionario
público para recibir esta inicialmente
en septiembre el candidata de vacuna y
ya a partir de diciembre como vacuna no
señor al vitesse en el marco legal
peruano a qué tipo de sanciones estarían
enfrentando entonces estos funcionarios
que han sido acusados o han sido
señalados dentro de este escándalo
bueno los funcionarios a nivel
ministerial en este caso serían dos
estamos frente a tres posibilidades no
es decir la sanción administrativa en
línea de carrera por ejemplo en el caso
de la ex canciller no pero también como
ministra está sujeto en términos
constitucionales al antejuicio
constitucional que supone un
procedimiento entre el congreso de la
república y la posibilidad de una
sanción de inhábiles de inhabilitación
hasta por diez años de igual modo esto
es parte de investigación que ya se
inició en el ministerio público
cualquier delito de corrupción o
aprovechamiento ilícito a nivel penal
por el cargo no y esto mismo a la ex
ministra de salud en el caso del
personal administrativo de que no tiene
que no es alto funcionario pues todo lo
que corresponde al ámbito del
disciplinario administrativo y penal